how you feeling
gotta be honest with you pal i've been
married
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by pete davidson
he's an actor and comedian you probably
know best from his time at saturday
night live he also has a new comedy
special on the way it's called
alive from new york and it's set to hit
netflix on february 25th
pete davidson welcome to the show thank
you for having me man
what's your mindset going into this
peter you a spicy food guy
no i have never eaten anything spicy uh
i am horrified
uh i was getting makeup in the makeup
room
uh because i need that [ __ ] and trinidad
james walks in and i was like oh wow
that's awesome uh how are you uh he's
like you do with hot ones i was like
yeah he's like
you don't need no makeup he was like you
need tissues
[Music]
it looks like though do you have like a
chili pepper tattoo
yeah no it's an italian horn but
unfortunately they look
[ __ ] exactly alike so yeah it might
as well be
[Music]
so i think that it's interesting that
you got your start and stand up at such
a young age taking the ferry in from
staten island when most of your peers
are probably taking the bus to after
school activities
what are the pros and cons of being
raised in comedy clubs and then coming
of age around
mostly much older comedians um
beaver mage is how many clubs is jesus
christ
no i was the only time i made friends
because uh people are like weird in
comedy and this type of field
so i got to like meet a lot of cool
people and it was like a really fun
escape to get away from
staten island you know why is it
important for comedians to spend three
hours at the comedy club even if they're
only performing a 15-minute set
um you're supposed to hang uh when you
start because you're just supposed to
like
be around half the stuff that i've ever
gotten has just been like
right place right time sometimes you'll
just hang out and chappelle will pop in
get to talk to like a tell or like you
get to talk to like all these great
comedians
what are the markings of success for a
comedy special like are you looking for
like
respect from peers does it really just
come down to how many people stream it
like what does success mean
um the first special i put out i was
like 22 and it wasn't
no i don't think i don't think it was
like horrible but just like
it was probably like the best i could do
at then and this is the best i could do
it like now
i just have some stuff i would like to
say i'm not looking for like respect
from anybody i just like i really love
stand up
and i'm [ __ ] stoked that i get to do
one with like netflix that's like pretty
[Music]
cool big jump
[Music]
still going in you better clear the bone
otherwise you'll be on reddit and
they'll call you a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so this summer you star in king of
staten island a judd apatow movie
loosely based on your upbringing in the
forgotten borough
yes sir how would you explain staten
island to someone you meet abroad who's
never heard of it
um staten island's like uh it's like if
you go on a time machine
like to 1980. it's just like
everything's the same
it's just a bunch of italian restaurants
um everybody's still kind of is stuck in
their ways
it's like adorable and like sad at the
same time
where does staten island's the loony bin
rank in the pantheon of great new york
city comedy clubs
oh dude the loot even was crazy it was a
it was a [ __ ]
like bowling alley it was a comedy club
inside of a bowling alley next to
la fitness and a wendy's so like it
sucked though cause like when you were
bombing you could hear people
bowling like it would be like birthday
parties he'd be like yeah so like you
know my mom's like crazy you know and
you just hear like spare
and you're like oh [ __ ] this is not
going very well
but i love that club that club was
clearly mob ron
um and it was so much fun though because
the owner would just go up to you and be
like we'll open next weekend
you know like it would be very like
weekend to weekend so like it was always
very fun
and like it was my first like um time
ever on stage
have you ever been to uh big nose kates
yes
why i think once or twice i think yeah
big nose skates is cool i mean like i'm
not much of a going out guy as you can
tell uh
i went out once or twice there and there
was bud light
are you one of these staten island
people that brag like staten island has
the best pizza in new york you know
there's a lot of
it doesn't l b is the best pizza in new
york by far
i don't think there's a com competitor
but staten island has the best like
overall pizza like if you can go to any
pizza place there you're
you're probably okay if i only have time
for one
the lighthouse museum or the tugboat
graveyard
oh no bo you got to go to the dump dude
you gotta go to the staten island dump
that's where the history is that's it is
yeah it's filled with like
old hondas and bodies you should go
there it's great
i'm pete's recommendation i gotta go
check it out are you ready to move on
absolutely fiji fire water in the three
spot
okay how are we doing so far that sounds
like a code
um i don't know man i'm getting a little
shaky over here
so p join saturday night live in 2014
becoming one of the youngest cast
members in the show's storied history
the make-a-wish program
sorry you always hear these stories like
drake getting bobby flay to cook for the
cast when you think about these
over-the-top generous things that guest
hosts have done to show their
appreciation yeah it was kind of
annoying because it was like during
writing night
really yeah it was like we were like in
the middle of like working on his show
and he's like yo bobby flay's here we're
like cool dude we have like [ __ ]
20 hours to [ __ ] put all this [ __ ]
together he interrupted the homework
he's very sweet he's very sweet he was
very nice
but it was wrong time do you have an
all-time favorite music performance
i like when future was on it i liked it
because lauren michaels called him the
future
and he calls the weekend weekend and
that's my favorite thing ever
and i also loved it because it was just
this moment where i was like oh cool
this is like [ __ ] i'm into
you know so it was like the first time
when i was there where i saw it kind of
switch to like now we have a baby on it
and [ __ ]
so it was a really cool moment my
heart's doing weird [ __ ]
that might just be because of the things
i do at home but
this is really intense this is like a
thing this is cool
i know this one is hot because there's
very little like work
on the label you think like they're
under selling over delivery yeah they're
like [ __ ] you it's hot
all right
[Music]
oh [ __ ] so from talking to a lot of
standups over the years it seems like
many feel pressured by the times we're
living in where
audiences seem to be in a heightened
state of awareness and then
it's so routine now for material to be
opportunistically taken out of context
right
where do you stand on performing at
college campuses now i know you swore it
off last year
yeah i did and then they were like money
and i was like so i'm going back
uh because i love money so much it's so
great
uh i know i it's really hard to perform
at colleges uh
but half of it i think is like in my
head too because there's this like
stigma it's like oh you can't say
anything because you'd be offended
you know which is why i tried to do the
whole nda thing i was trying to shoot a
special it wasn't like i'm like you
can't
talk about my stuff it's like once a
joke gets out and it's in print
and it's out of context and you don't
see me do it or you see how
i say it then like it could mean the
[ __ ] most horrible thing ever
thing about millennials is they're very
passionate people like they want to help
but they have no information behind it
they just they hear like help that
you're like they [ __ ] like they don't
even like look
or read or do anything because they're
just so instant
you know so that's why you know that's
why it's so difficult
[Music]
i was taking a piece of the bathroom i
was like i can't believe all the
major celebrities have taken giant
dumpsters
[Laughter]
so i just you know sat at it for a
second appreciated the moment
all right so pete at the five mark we do
this thing called explain that gram
where we do a deep dive on our guests
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context
can't do it for you because yes you got
rid of the internet
a year ago yes how do you think that's
affected your life do you think it's
improved your life
it's definitely helped my mental health
uh i think
it's just i don't think it's good for
anybody but especially anybody that has
like a job
around this stuff uh because you just
you see every comment
also like no one gives a [ __ ] about your
[ __ ] shoes or your watch
or your truck or any of that [ __ ] so
you're all corny
we're all laughing yeah well you know
what pete you still have picks on the
internet no i do i have some rough ones
we still pulled some stuff that we're
gonna have you explain okay pete
and first up it's you courtside at
madison square garden with chris rock
he was very upset that i was the guy he
didn't even say hello before
like there's a room where you meet up
there and he didn't even say hello and
then he figured out that i was the only
other
like person on tv there and he was like
hey
but i was so excited because i got the
picture i like going with uh
josh safty he's really fun to watch the
game with cause he talks to the refs
she'll run by he'll be like come on
janet that wasn't cool janet like
you know come on man look for the three
seconds janet and once in a while
the the ref will like laugh or whatever
and it's the [ __ ] funniest thing ever
it just feels so like you feel like a
kid again would you like oh i got the
ref to laugh
here you are dear walk in the runway at
alexander wang
nosferatu 2020 baby alexander wag is a
very nice gentleman
uh i think his clothes are sick and he
was like would you like to do this and i
was like it would be an honor kind of
like this show and i was like [ __ ] yeah
i'm good you literally not do that
there's a really funny photo of anna
wintour very disappointed that i walk by
that's in my room somewhere they have a
tough job man those models they have to
eat like [ __ ] mints
and like yeah they don't even get to
like drink water it doesn't get talked
they don't even get the weird deodorant
they just
they have a rough job those ladies you
know just jeweling living on jewels
what do you remember about being on
stage with machine gun kelly follow up
where did you get a shane falco jersey
thank you dude a good i appreciate that
because a good friend of mine uh were
very into keanu reeves
and uh peep the double watch spongebob
sorry uh that's closest watch i was
wearing it because he didn't want to
lose it
um i got it online we're very big keanu
reeves fans but before the [ __ ] wave
i once there's this movie uh called
knock knock
have you seen it no so like it's this
keatoris movie you gotta see it anyway
long story short these two girls that
are like young
raid his house when his family's away
they like force him to [ __ ] like they
will not let him go
so they have sex with him or whatever
and then at the end uh well they're
about to kill him he just goes
what did you expect it was free pizza
then ever since then i've been the
biggest keanu reeves fan
i know that makes no sense but uh yeah
love the shane falco jersey
you want me to eat all of these chicken
wings
and not cry it can't
be done
[Music]
oh it is sometimes we speak too soon
with hot sauce
no i speak too soon a lot in life
self-awareness joke mate my pot was good
so you've been on tv a long time getting
recognized in public i'm sure that
that's been happening for you
but becoming a target for paparazzi in
more recent years has to have been a
strange experience
is there any humor that you can find in
being chased around by photographers or
is it all just one giant nuisance with
no upside
well it's really annoying because like i
live in staten island and they come
there now because like ariana grande
made me all famous and stuff
so she like it's all her fault uh it is
she sent the wolves on me now it's uh
she made me and created me or whatever
they say
um so i it sucks it's so embarrassing
because like i have a family
that like my mom has to go to work you
know and there's these [ __ ] weirdos
outside
and it's embarrassing and it sucks and i
like to smoke weed and be high in public
and it's very scary when someone's like
because you know you feel like you're in
the future when there's paparazzi
outside does it affect how you dress
like is there a part of you that's like
i gotta get this fit off for the daily
mail
no i stopped i don't really try to dress
i used to
when i had the gram because you just
scroll through like hypebeast and you're
like ooh
off-white shoes i guess that's what the
cool kids are wearing and then you
realize like when you're not online that
that's what broke kids think that's what
rich people should wear
and it's lame so yeah i've stopped
dressing at all
or caring about anything like that at
all it's a really great feeling once you
finally just give up
[Music]
oh no there's a rough one
this is really hard now
[Music]
oh all right dom's coming in she always
uh
senses when somebody could use a fresh
one careful around your eyes pete
yeah okay
[Music]
i'm gonna start crying kill that oat
milk yeah i did
[Music]
thank you man
so in the wake of uncut gems there have
been all these highlight videos
[ __ ] movie ever excellent movie oh my
god best last 20 minutes that movie's
the best
[ __ ] cinema i've ever seen in my life
and then as a byproduct of that there
are all these highlight videos emerging
of adam sandler playing basketball
crying thinking about the end of uncut
gems
but you can't touch your face right
another rule
well there's no rules but i just i don't
want to i don't want to exacerbate the
situation
[Music]
this is where it's making me nervous oh
no this is where this is a new one
okay cool i'm just gonna cry it's okay
that's what people want
is someone who also plays pickup
basketball from time to time
who is the most athletic comedian you've
ever seen who sandler
really sound like a [ __ ] ball dude
and he plays like dirty
him and his boys it's pretty great he's
like really really good
and competitive he has like a he'll back
you down and like he'll really [ __ ]
like at first you're like this is cool
[ __ ]
uh at first you're like this is really
cool it's i'm playing ball with adam
sandler and then you're like ow
you know you really hurt me man
do you have a favorite memory from that
day that you got to
shag fly balls and do bp with your uh
mlb doppelganger christian yelich
dude i got [ __ ] yelled at they didn't
tell holy [ __ ] okay
they didn't tell the [ __ ] team that i
was coming
they only uh it was just
a surprise with this nerdy little pr guy
that i met he was like hey we should
surprise christian
i was like yeah cool dude that'll be
sick you know like of course i would
love to do that
so i get there they dress me up like
them they film me they make this whole
big thing and i
and i just go out there during stretches
and i'm like what's up everybody and
they're all like what the [ __ ]
and then the batting coach goes son if
you don't get the [ __ ] off my [ __ ]
field
in front of all the nba mlv players
uh and then i just like the rest of the
game just sat
next to the bench then after they were
like would you like to be christian i
was like
i guess and he was like hey man i want
to strike some players
and i was like yes please
everybody just feels bad all right
all right pete yes sir it's that time of
the show
okay the bomb beyond insanity
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh it's all right
[ __ ] you dude serious over here
holy shitball
[Music]
that's right [ __ ]
yeah as a rap fan
i did as a rap fan where do you stand on
eminem these days
there seems to be this divide people are
like he's the greatest lyricist of all
time
versus others that are like you know
he's like a fart joke uncle screaming
into the void
no he's obviously one of the best of all
time but he's annoying my friend
he's not doing a good job at it multiple
friends
you know he won't leave any of my
friends alone because
having gotten your break from wilding
out and doing shows with nick cannon
were you able to pick his side
[Music]
but close at one oh my god
oh yeah because you know
your buddy machine gun kelly and eminem
they traded diss tracks
yes sir that old man got so angry in his
little cave
oh my friend killed that ass that was
awesome
so i know you got stuck with the bill at
that much publicized dinner that you had
with kid cudi and kanye last year yeah
what's different about having kanye on
snl it seems like
everything's different when he comes to
the when he comes in the show
uh yeah it's really kind of a show when
kanye comes and says oh what kind of
goes
anywhere truly oh kanye's thing
i'm not [ __ ] around i'm not trying to
fight this [ __ ] it's da bomb
wow ah okay pete yeah
we got two two wings to go
how you feeling gotta be honest with you
pal
i've been
oh [ __ ] dude i'm really having a rough
time
i feel you pete i feel you pete i'm
gonna do it but i might pass out
well i'm right here with you i will say
this is heroic pete oh thank you just
trying to be like my dad
no this is my 911.
[Music]
hey dom's standing right by she's got
oat milk she's got tissues
holy [ __ ]
am i the worst no
pete if anything i'd make a case for
best are you sure
yes [ __ ] dude i'm honestly i'm not
trying before i
really can't right now it's okay it's
okay let's show for a second
oh my goodness wow you got to get your
head checked
that's coming from me
wow that's crazy i don't think i'm doing
a whole [ __ ] bone no more
sorry reddit
don't worry about that
this one is the widowmaker from
australia
[Music]
my mom should have this one
still god
okay widowmaker make me a widow
dude this stuff thing this thing has
stuff on it
okay okay
all right pete that's good that's good
thank you that's good okay
so i read um in your paper magazine
profile
that you turned your basement your mom's
basement with my basement yeah
into what sounds like the greatest man
cave in the five boroughs
can you paint the scene for us because
it does seem like
a lot went into the details there yeah
so
me and my mom bought a house together
because it's the stat night of the dream
um and uh [ __ ] i just like
put a bunch of tvs like a computer and
like a couple beanbags
and you know it's like a [ __ ] cave
and uh it's oh my god dude i'm
i don't even remember what you asked
it's all right we'll race to the finish
line here pete i'm so sorry
is it like a video game situation down
there no it's much more
movies movies and drugs
i like smoking weed to do mushrooms and
watching movies and like
just relaxing and like forgetting where
you are for a little bit
it's a really nice little pad oh my
goodness
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
i am going to forbid you
okay yeah from doing that thank you i'm
gonna get in your way on that
thank you very much because i would have
done it
but he says over here dom take this take
this
all right
okay pete davidson here we are at the
end of the hot ones gauntlet
we've touched on many of the finer
points of pete davidson
but an even lesser known fact is that
you have
multiple harry potter themed tattoos i
do i was into that
at least six according to
bodyartguru.com
which documented some 104 pete davidson
tattoos did you know that
no i didn't even know i had that many
that's crazy how many of those harry
potter
tattoos can you show us right now and
can you explain each one
sure uh this
is uh that triangle thing that they all
have the deathly hallows thing
uh this is a lightning bolt that i got
uh that's harry potter and uh
this is the phoenix from the order of
the phoenix
and uh this is a dire wolf i still
haven't finished game of thrones but
the wolves are sick um
and that's that's i think all the ones
that we can see right now
well look at you pete davidson
all the way down the hot ones gauntlet
it was a heroic performance if i've ever
seen one i'm humbled
sitting on this end of the table i am
embarrassed and mortified and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my friend
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
uh plea the really only thing [ __ ]
besides my special but [ __ ] that
please go see big time adolescence jason
orlie is a genius
and he works so hard on it and it's
really really a nice film
and uh go see uncut gems just keep going
and see that movie that's the best
[ __ ] movie i've ever seen in my life
all right thank you for having me very
much all right good job pete good job
all right
awesome thank you so much for having me
i really appreciate it thank you
oh my god wow that [ __ ] was no joke dude
i did it though i did it
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in
with a very exciting sauce update now as
i'm sure you're aware we have a new show
hot ones the game show on true tv
featuring sauces that are off the charts
hot
i'm talking about the brain burner the
eye of the scorpion
the constrictor all extreme heat with
beautiful labels
designed by tattoo artists of note and
guess what
they can be yours that's right brain
burner
eye of the scorpion the constrictor
they're all available at heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to order and
don't forget to check out
hot ones the game show tuesdays 10 p.m
eastern
nine central on true tv live the show
if you dare bring the pepperdome to your
living room
and remember milkshakes are for winners
only